Speaker 1: We are taking calls via discord
and we are going to hear next from I hope
I pronounce this correctly, is it Saraqeb
from Austin?
Speaker 4: Hi, I'm Bakhmina out at
Speaker 1: Sara Saurabh, OK, what's going
on?
Speaker 4: My question was regarding the minimum
wage.
Why does it have to be a fixed value?
Why can't it be a dependent of a couple of
factors like the location as well as the inflation
rate?
Speaker 1: It absolutely can be.
I mean, it's not the way it's structured.
But I've proposed this and I've said before
that state by state, there are dramatically
different costs of living and and prevailing
wages.
And what counts as a livable wage is very
different in rural Alabama than it is in New
York City.
So I think there's a couple of different things.
And you're on to some of them.
One would be to index inflation is tough because
I don't I don't know that we have different
inflation numbers by state.
I've I've only ever looked at national inflation
numbers so you could index the minimum wage
in general to inflation.
But I don't know that.
Speaker 4: Right.
Let's call one of the problems that we have
to keep updating these values every five years
or 10 years.
Yes.
And it won't put the pressure on small businesses
if they won't have to increase just five percent
every year the wage, rather than it being
a chunk like a couple of dollars or five dollars
for 10 years.
Speaker 1: No doubt.
No doubt.
I mean, for me, I think the bigger differences
would come from adjusting the minimum wage
based on cost of living, which is dramatically
different.
But then here's a complicated question.
If a lot of people are working in one place
but commuting in from a different place, how
do you account for that in terms of is the
cost of is the wage adjusted to the cost of
living where they're working or where they're
living?
I mean, there are things to figure out, but
I think that you're absolutely correct in
that in a country as large and economically
diverse as the United States, I think you
need a baseline minimum wage below which no
state goes.
But more more nuance is probably better in
this case.
Yeah, I agree.
All right, how are things in Austin these
days?
Speaker 4: Yeah, it's pretty good.
The climate is very nice right
Speaker 1: now, I bet.
All right.
Very good.
I appreciate the call.
Thank you.
My pleasure.
Let's see who else we want to hear from.
There are just so many people eager to get
on.
Let's go next to Ethan from Santa Monica.
Ethan in their.
Speaker 3: Hey, yeah, can you hear me?
I can hear you.
OK, so I was wondering your thoughts on the
for the People Act and more specifically,
the actions some Democrats have been proposing
to circumvent the filibuster.
Speaker 1: Remind me, though, which one is
the for the I rarely know proposals, by the
way.
Speaker 3: Yeah, that's H.R. one.
Speaker 1: Oh, OK.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, of course.
OK.
Speaker 3: So obviously, cinnamon and have
said that they're not going to get rid of
the filibuster as a whole.
Yes, but the Senate has amended it in the
past for budget reconciliation.
Right.
Do you think the Senate should edit the filibuster
for, quote unquote, democracy, reconciliation
so that only 50 votes are required in order
to pass H.R. one?
Because I don't know.
I don't know if I'd better alternative.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I don't know.
And I've talked about this before.
I think that just doing away with the filibuster
changing from 60 to 50, I do believe it's
a double edged sword.
And what we've learned is that these completely
amoral right wingers will use every tool they
have against Democrats when given the opportunity,
and then they'll act outraged when Democrats
do the same thing.
A great example is the Merrick Garland nomination
in Obama's last year and then putting Amy
covid buried on the Supreme Court in like
a week or whatever.
You know, they're just total hypocrites.
So the question is, one, do we, quote, stoop
to their level with the filibuster?
I don't have any moral opposition.
However, I worry about how it would ultimately
come back to backfire dramatically against
Democrats.
I think that from what I've read, I like the
idea of going back to it being a real talking
filibuster and requiring 40 people in the
chamber at all times in order to keep debate
going.
This will do two things.
It'll make it logistically more difficult
for Republicans to keep it up.
And then, number two, it will also make it
more publicly visible when Republicans are
being obstructionists.
So I'm kind of leaning in that direction.
I've not seen, like, something super convincing
that says just blow up the filibuster altogether
right now.
Speaker 3: Well, do you think that could actually
last indefinitely?
Because obviously right now, as it is, they
can basically completely block H.R. one from
passing.
And if they continue to like, you know, if
it's a talking filibuster, obviously the intention
with that is that they wouldn't be able to
do that indefinitely, which is sort of their
whole point of the filibuster.
Yes.
Speaker 1: You're saying that if that's what
Democrats decided to do in terms of a rule
change, couldn't Republicans then just undo
that as well next time they take control?
Exactly.
Yes, they could.
But my point is it might be a way to get some
things done now without blowing it up all
together, which could backfire dramatically.
Speaker 3: Yeah, I guess, you know, especially
if they instituted some sort of fifty vote
alternative for democracy, reconciliation,
I think, you know, for Republicans somehow
get a trifecta, they could completely use
that to, you know, add all these voting restrictions
and all that nationally.
So.
Right.
I guess it just depends on your sort of philosophy
per person.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
And I'm also thinking about it from a pragmatic
standpoint, which is what are ways to get
some things done now without then having disasters
happen in the future in an almost certain
way.
And it's a complicated thing.
I don't know the answer.
I think what I feel strongly about, though,
is just leaving it the way it is now is not
likely to be the best outcome.
Speaker 3: OK.
All right.
Thank you so much.
All right, my friend.
Speaker 1: Thank you.
Great question.
Very, very important topic and will be a determining
factor, I would say, in what successes there
are in this first couple of years of Joe Biden's
presidency.